تحول بحر المانش من طوق نجاه لالاف
المهاجرين الحالمين بالمستقبل افضل الى
مصيده موت تحول دون عبورهم بين عالم فقير
واخر واحد بالفراص مره اخرى وقع في فخ
الموت زورق على متنه 40 مهاجرا يعملون
بالوصول الى اليابسه البريطانيه
قياده جديده متخصصه في الزوارق الصغيره في
القناه اتفاقيات مع البانيا وفرنسا تطبيق
صارم لقوانين الهجره والنصوص تشريعيه
صريحه لاول مره
تعون فرنسا وبريطانيا على انقاذ الثوره لا
يخفي الخلافه بين الطرفين على قضيه
المهاجرين
وبغض النظر عن التنسيق والخلاف تصعب
بريطانيا الى حل سريع لهذه المعضله بعد ان
شدد رئيس الوزراء ريش سوناك على ان
المهاجرين غير القانونيين يستغلون ما وصفه
بكرمه بريطانيا
يقولولي
لا يمكنك البقاء
لكن مقابل وجهه النظر هذه يا عيب فريق على
لندن ما يصفه بالازدواجيه في التعامل مع
المهاجرين فطريق القادمين من اوكرانيا على
سبيل المثال سهله ومعبده اما الاقل حظا
وبخاصه اولئك المهاجرون من سوريا
وافغانستان وغيرهم فغالبا ما تغلق الابواب
الفرنسيه خلفهم والبريطانيه امامهم ولا
يبقى لهم سوى البحر وزوارق اشبه بتوابيت
عائمه
انس نماسي العربيه